uh danny chow is an engineering lead at
t tech john feast inc and a feast
contributor previously danny was a
technical lead at google working on
end-to-end machine learning problems
within google workspace helping build
privacy aware about platforms data
pipelines and working with research and
product teams to deliver large-scale ml
powered enterprise functionality danny
holds a bachelor's degree in computer
science from mit
and since this is his time i'll hand off
the mic
you
you take over
go home
so yes we are here to talk about feature
source today
uh so let me just dive right in
um
yeah so i already kind of got the intro
but i
i saw just kind of skip past this so let
me kind of like quickly first start with
a quick plug for feast so what is feast
exactly
uh feast is an open source feature store
and we have a pretty rich
connector ecosystem already and a lot of
it is community
power so we you know we integrate with
gcp aws azure um soon kind of snowflake
is coming on board as well et cetera et
cetera we have an active community with
2000 plus members on slack and also
bi-weekly community calls
and on the right here is kind of this
hero image that we've thrown together
and i'll kind of be diving into some of
these components in the talk
but below that you can see here's a
bunch of teams that some of them are
running it some of them are contributing
it often it's both people companies who
try to use feast they understand
the code base and they can actually
contribute back to make it work better
for the use case
right
so quick
agenda of the talk today so i'll be
talking about what are some common
machine learning challenges that
both you know data scientists and
engineers face
what exactly is a feature store and what
kind of how does it help solve some of
these challenges
there will be a brief demo that i'm
going to showcase a feast
and then i'm going to jump into some
other stuff which is like how do you
deploy fees in a production environment
what are some typical patterns we see
and then i'm going to jump into some use
cases uh where and kind of show how
feast fits into somebody's specific
problem space
and then
i think that this is actually a little
bit out of date i'm not going to jump
into the road map but happy to take
questions about that if people are
interested
so yeah i wanted to take a quick step
back and highlight what is the machine
learning pipeline look like
from not even that long ago like maybe
in the last
just like couple years ago this is the
absolute norm even today it's still
fairly normal for this
uh what it looks like is
uh if you're a data scientist and or
data engineer trying to build a model
you'll have some sort of historical data
stored in a data lake right and maybe
some some part of this data lake is
you have events that come in that will
eventually pipe into the data lake but
ultimately the data scientists are
working mainly with this data lake so
like s3 files databases et cetera right
and you'll run some sort of etl pipeline
where you make a
some sort of job maybe it's like spark
maybe it's a mapreduce job that will
transform join and clean uh prepare this
data for
to generate features for the model
training right so that's kind of what uh
um the data scientist does and then at
that point is where the engineers kind
of take over right like okay let me
deploy this model you've trained that
you think is
uh really good and i have to this
engineer has to then find okay what's we
have the set of features that we need
let me find all the places to get those
features and then transform them in the
same way and then that's going to then
feed some sort of
output model prediction to the to the
end user right
yeah and then kind of you'll notice that
there's also this arrow from this uh
events and stream processing into the
online features uh that's just calling
out that often you do need features at
serving time and a lot oftentimes this
is coming from uh you know events that
are coming in real time
so yeah i'm just going to jump into some
challenges here so
one of the challenges here is as a data
scientist generating training data is
really hard so we're looking primarily
at the left side of this diagram here
and what do we mean by that so
first of all there's a lot of
infrastructure needs here that is
exposed to data scientists so if you
need to do deal with a high volume of
data
you're gonna have to deal with some sort
of distributed compute distributed uh
you know batch processing
pipeline such as
a mapreduce job or a spark job right
sometimes you want to do high volume
transfer transformations on this data
and that also requires kind of
leveraging that computes
in many cases you also need to have
access to different kinds of event
sources and so you need some sort of
stream processing layer that's built in
here as well
secondly joins are really hard and so
what i'm referring to here is
you often have
a lot of different kinds of data you
want to pull from to create so for
example if you're trying to build a uh
the canonical like movie recommendation
system right like you have some features
about
a user who's trying to find movies to
look at and some features around a movie
you gotta join all this these different
data sources together
and it's often kind of tricky to build a
point in time correct view of this so
you to have the features
accurate to that point in time like you
you don't want to have
future future values leaking in that can
bias the model or give it an unfair
advantage and that will lead to some
training serving skew
right
and then finally if you have a new
feature idea how do you actually go
about doing that in this world you would
actually go back into this
this job and you know change some logic
there rerun this whole pipeline to read
load data from your data lake and
generate the new training set right so
in sure this can be fairly slow and
complex
a lot of stuff has changed since then
including like you know the advent of
data warehouses as a centric
central layer of compute for this and
we're going to talk a little bit more
about how feast plays into that
later on
the second bit here is that you're kind
of working with two different
environments you have a training
environment which is the data scientist
world and you have a serving environment
where the engineer comes into play right
and
there's a lot of nuance here some of
them has to do with just like you have
different requirements you need to
satisfy such as
serving time you need low latency but
high qps by training time you care about
just processing a large amount of volume
uh but some other kind of things to call
here is you know i mentioned training
serving sku uh there's also a lot of
room for error here in your pipeline
like often these these pipelines to
generate training data you're doing some
sort of data cleaning some sort of down
sampling some sort of sampling um and
that can lead to a certain distribution
of data that may be different from what
you're seeing as serving time
right and so that's kind of what we call
training serving sku it's like well my
model said they was going to do really
well in offline data but it doesn't
match what i see in online results right
so that debugging flow
is often caused because we have this
disparity between these environments
the second
key thing to clue into here is that
where you pull data from could be
different too right like in
a training time you're pulling from this
data lake at serving time polar informed
data like it's too slow so you need some
other way to get
uh features that are available so every
kind of team has their own different way
of tackling this problem
and the final challenge i'm going to
call here is that
there is a lot of duplication of efforts
so
each kind of set of you know whether
you're like an ammo engineer or data
science team or whatever when you're
solving a new model you generally kind
of have to start from scratch like you
maybe have some sort of
shared knowledge with your peers you can
talk to people but there's no real
centralized means for collaboration
on the coding level right and it's also
very hard for you to have a layer of
standardization and
everyone's kind of clean their data
differently everyone's kind of
transforming their data differently
and
it's also just kind of hard to figure
out you know
what is the prior here like what have
people already had success doing here
so that's another kind of duplication of
effort challenge here
and so yeah and through the feature
stores so what is a feature store a
feature store aims to
specifically optimize for kind of these
two personas we've defined here like the
the data scientist and the engineer
where it helps manage
ingestion and storage of the streaming
and batch data so that data scientists
no longer have to worry about like you
know how do i get all the data to kind
of pipeline together
we also it also provides a standardized
definition of features and
transformations
and that is consistently applied
for the data scientist and engineer
there no longer is a communication that
you have to do in the old world a data
scientist would have a model and they
kind of just like throw that over the
wall to the engineer and hope and pray
that some you know the engineer is able
to accurately reproduce that right so
feature servers will help um ensure that
consistency
and on top of that there's also a
registry discovery and registration
component of this so data scientists can
define features and transformations and
then learn what other data scientists
are doing through kind of a discovery
discovery interface
uh
i mentioned the point about point in
time correctness and feature source
typically will just manage a joint for
you so you define kind of what's the
rough shape and
data sources that you care about and
then it'll
feast or feature sources typically will
help manage ensuring that point in time
correctness
and finally there is a
component of
validation uh qual data quality
monitoring where
you want to ensure that whatever data
you're kind of going that you're
throwing into your training pipeline
that matches what your expectations are
that there's no more outliers and also
that applies to at the serving time so
often feature stores will help manage
with that
layer of your system as well
yeah so kind of this is just kind of
reiterating that
feature source kind of break this up so
that you don't need to have as much
communication between these parties you
know on one side whether you're like a
data engineer or data scientist you can
um kind of just feed data in once and
now apparently everyone's okay with that
right and then you have the the model
training which is isolated by just you
read from feasts and that's kind of all
you need to worry about and similarly at
the serving time um the data the
engineers don't need to really talk to
the data scientists they can just look
at what feast what they've declared in
feast and interface with that
um yeah so now i'm going to go a little
bit into
kind of some of the details of how
feasts in particular works
so this is a it's pretty standard flow
so
a data scientist here will define
features such as features that i've
described in this kind of left area
and then register that with feature
store feast and then at that point there
will be some transformations that are
executed depending on which path you
take where like if you're trying to
get training data then it's going to
execute over that large
batch
of data that you care about and
in the online flow you want that same
execution transformation to be executed
so on the left side here you can see on
the top we define a feature around
kind of pointing to certain columns in a
big table bigquery table
and in the bottom there you see a way to
define transformations and fees which we
call on-demand feature views and this
lets you do row level transforms so here
you can see that there's some some data
that's available around light long and
it will do some sort of geo hashing for
downstream uh usage right
yeah this is kind of like getting back
to kind of what i already talked about
but you can
there you want to have a consistent way
to access this data whether you're
uh trying to serve features or get
training data and you can just just see
that in the interface you know on the
top
box here this is the
the api for calling getting online
features and in the bottom this is how
you generate your training data and they
look fairly identical right
and that's very much by design so that
uh you know you can kind of just eyeball
him and recognize yes this is doing
roughly the same thing
and
finally so this is an area that i think
feature stores take a different stab at
depending on which which which features
you are but
feast currently has a certain some sort
of method some sort of interface by
which you can
write and publish features and then
reuse them and discover them right so
teams can easily reason about what what
they're doing
this is an area that we're looking to
kind of expand more into and build a
robust ui to kind of help you visualize
everything that's happening but right
now the raw data is available too
uh to users
so yeah now i'm going to walk through
and kind of it's a somewhat contrived
but it's an end-to-end use case of how
you might integrate this into an ml
pipeline right so
the let me just set the scene here right
you are
trying to predict whether users are
defaulting on their loan you're getting
kind of this you want to build a model
that will predict that for at serving
time and you have access to a bunch of
historical data around loans and maybe
some features around the user and maybe
some features even around like the
location of where this loan is trying to
happen right
um and
we have a github repo that has all this
code so you can actually walk through
yourself very easily
i'm just going to kind of go through the
salient points here and
you guys can run it yourself i see it
happening in real time
so
this here i basically just wanted to
kind of give you a quick sense of what
the data are working with here so
the
bottom
table here is actually
contains the the target dot variable
here which is loan status so you might
think of this as like one is
uh it kind of went through and
zero it kind of it there was a default
or something something like that right
this middle is kind of some some
features around specifically the zip
code as a primary key and then this top
one is really focused on this uh
wha what looks like dob ssn and that's
kind of date of birth social security
number
obviously fake data we're not kind of
showing social security numbers here but
that's kind of the the user level uh
features that we have access to
so
yeah in fees you would define a
an entity and an entity really maps to
a you can think of this as a primary key
so in in the old and what i just
described you have some
uh one table that was specifically
focused on a person as the primary key
and then another one i was focused on
like zip code specific information so
those are both the entities here
here you can see that actually we're
able to
register in the data source as well
and there's this other configuration
that you can do to actually help set
this up but this is a that's a one-time
setup thing for just getting the right
credentials and permissions and
everything
uh here what you're seeing here is that
there's actually a query
that is querying over the s3 files that
you have using right shift and that's
that's being done through spectrum
to federate that query for all future
kind of data transformations etc
yeah next kind of need to find features
we've already kind of taken a look at
this this is mostly referencing that
person entity that we defined before and
call out here's some features and the
types
that we care about
and then you call feast apply so this
this kind of looks like um you know for
those of you who are familiar with tools
like terraform it kind of looks like
that like well there's a there's it will
be a feast plan kind of method a feast
apply and it uses kind of what you
define as a declarative interface for
registering features that you want and
deploying the infrastructure to being
able to
be able to pull those features at
training time or or a serving time
and then there's this concept of
materialization so this is a basically
what this is doing is
pulling the latest values that you need
for online surveys so as serving time
you really just need
the most recent data you don't need a
huge amount of history there just to be
able to you want just the data you need
to be able to serve your prediction and
so that's what materialization is doing
it's loading data and then throwing that
into what we call the online server
which is just a low latency
store that we use to give you
features at serving time
and yeah and then you kind of fetch the
features and you can do model training
here so you can see that
we're calling the familiar get
historical features interface here and
gain the training data frame
and then we're able to kind of drop the
target variable in this and just go
ahead and train so it's like super
straightforward once you've already
defined it and
at this point you've basically
transitioned to feature engineering out
of
um
your regular python code and into the
actual feature view kind of paradigm
but what that gives you is also now you
you're less bottlenecked by the engineer
like often what we've heard is that
data you have a lot of data scientists
and you have very few engineers to
support all of them and so this will
really
unblock the engineer because the
engineer can just say let me just pull
the same kind of set of features
using easy feast
and
now i'm just ready to make my prediction
and it's all going to kind of be
kind of up-to-date and transform
consistently
yeah so kind of as a quick recap
we
used feast to
register some data sources and and to
find some features so that and that's
kind of done by some sort of like data
engineer right to or an admin who has
access to all the data sources
and then and then afterwards the data
scientist has a very clear interface
where they
they know roughly what data sources
exist they can generate a point in time
correct uh training set using the
features they defined and now they can
train that model
and prepare it for for serving and kind
of it's super easy for the engineer to
serve those predictions and they no
longer have to scour different data
sources to fetch the right feature
values they
need and
yeah so now i want to kind of dive into
what are some common deployment patterns
that we see
with feast so how do you actually make
this work like for for this online
serving
stack you often need to handle very high
scale so presumably there's some sort of
like cloud like a scalability component
here right um so this is this diagram on
the right side roughly gets at what
one common pattern that we see
right so on the bottom there you see
these batch sources and that this is
like some sort of data warehouse or some
some sort of like you know s3 or gcs
where you store your data
and this is really really optimized for
compute because we're using the data
warehouse as a compute layer and people
often use dbt as a way to
do some pre-processing some
pre-transformations on this data some
data cleaning and then they register
that resultant data with feast
right
there's also a way for you to
register your events in the stream
sources such as with kafka kinesis and
push that data directly to the online
store and i guess why do you really need
that the reason you want that is because
you need you want access to very very
recent features
and uh the most recent version of that
is coming from your streaming events so
we allow you to kind of ingest that into
feast and that that will map well to
kind of a certain
uh batch source that you that you've
defined
and then finally kind of there is that
materialization stuff i talked about so
we often see users will use something
like airflow to orchestrate and schedule
materialization fairly regularly
depending on what their future freshness
requirements are
right
and then uh for training you're kind of
just down there you can
spin up the feast sdk in your training
environment and now you can call it uh
get historical features
for the serving component you need to
deploy this feature server somewhere
to actually
expose an interface to
query these features so there is a first
class integration that feast has built
with aws lambda so you can kind of just
very quickly uh let me just
advance this is roughly how you would do
it
so for the most part here you just
define
feature servers enabled and you kind of
throw in your your execution role
and now all you have to do is feast
apply and that will actually deploy the
feature server for you and give you an
endpoint that you can now just query
from right um
so so that's kind of what feast has
built we also see people who build
packages up into the docker image and
deploy into their own kubernetes
clusters
um
yeah and i guess the final point here is
that
people also do version their their
models with
with feast so there's a concept of a
feature service which is a collection of
features that you often tie directly to
a model and you can actually uh we have
a guide on the feast documentation but
you can save the exact set of features
that you have with a specific model
version and now you can kind of track
that with
tools like ml flow for example
i'm not going to dive kind of too too
deep into this diagram on the right but
you know we we have users come to us and
they have a variety of different needs
and they're able to integrate these
fairly well one big kind of
current trend that we're seeing is that
recommender systems are just really
really big so that's kind of what this
uh right side is it's kind of painting
you know here's a picture of a
recommender system that's trying to
recommend users to items and you can see
that there's all these touch points
signaled by this
blue feast icon
and feast does kind of help you abstract
some of the complexity out of what
typically is actually still a fairly
complex
problem which is building recommender
systems but we also see people coming to
us for like fraud detection which needs
has very low latency requirements
or personalization you know you need
some sort of aggregate like historical
uh preferences for example stored in an
online store form et cetera et cetera
and yeah that's all i had for you guys
so
um posted some links here any kind of
questions
i left this diagram on the right hand
just as like a quick reminder of uh
what feast does
starting to roll in from uh
keith you mentioned feast using ml flow
have you used
feast with ku ku flow what about feast
with both
yes um so
with that question we do actually have a
pretty close partnership with kubeflow
and we talk with them all the time so
there are folks who've used at least
earlier versions of piece of cube flow i
think there's some investigation on our
part to
help
kind of close that gap again
but we definitely see people already
using that today
the second question is around you know
is feast useful in 100 batch context
and actually a lot of our users do come
to us for this as well and so there's
two value adds that they get one of them
is that
um
that point in time join uh is
is a complexity that they just don't
want to manage and results in some
dramatic simplification of their overall
stack uh the other bit is
as team scale up they do want some sort
of central way to discover features and
uh collaborate on functionality so
people do
in both of those use cases want to use
feature stores
uh and then david you know is feast used
and deployed widely
uh i guess that's kind of a hard
question you know it depends on what you
mean by deployed widely i had a kind of
an earlier slide
that calls out here some some users who
are using it but there's certainly
a good mix of
large companies or like medium to large
test companies for using fees today um
some of them i can't really call out
because there's
they haven't publicly announced it for
pr reasons i can't really call them out
but there's there's a couple
there's a dozen listed on the website
and then we also have in our slide
channel you can see all these people who
are using it for personal projects or
masters projects as well
um what is the relationship between fees
and tech time sorry go ahead oh any any
uh
any huge international banks using it
uh
i
can't confirm or deny that
um mostly yeah i think there
anybody who anybody in that finances
yeah
wink once for jp morgan went twice for
goldman sachs
uh yeah um
yeah let me let me kind of get through
some of the other questions so like
what's the relationship between feast
and tech time so tekton is one of the
uh
main contributors to feast that being
said so we have a couple of official
maintainers we have gojek
who actually originally created feast
and then there's also twitter and
shopify are both active maintainers so
they they're using it in their internal
ml systems to build their internal
feature stores on top of feast so kind
of there's a couple of like key
maintainers but generally kind of feasts
you can think of fees as they're trying
to optimize for different goals here
like tech time is obviously a business
and feast is more trying to solve for
the community issues and so
there are definitely cases where uh we
clash in terms of like oh what do we
prioritize and it ends up being
different right so that but
tekton is kind of a key contributor
to feast today
thank you so much for being a speaker
this year
yeah of course you enjoy the rest of the
conference and have a have a wonderful
day
sounds good thank you